اعلنت ميته الشركه المالكه لفيسبوك
وانستجرام عن دخولها سباق التفاعل مع
الذكاء للصناعي واسم المنتج لاما لاما هو
نموذج جديد للغه تشغل انظمه الذكاء
الاصطناعي الحديثه مثل روبوت الدردشه
لكن لاما لن يكون مثل تشاجي او بنج التابع
لمايكروسوفت فهو ليس روبوت محادثات هو
نظام سيكون متاحا لمساعده الباحثين على
تطوير اعمالهم بالاضافه الى منظمات
المجتمع المدني والاوساط الاكاديميه تقول
الشركه عبر بيان نشرته الجمعه ان نظام
اظهر نتائج واعده البينه شرى خصوصا الى
تلخيص المواد المكتوبه والمهام الاكثر
تعقيدا مثل حل نظريات رياضيه ماذا عن باقي
المحدثات الروبوتيه نتعرف عليها معنا
شركات التكنولوجيا الكبرى تخوض سباقا قويا
لدمج تكنولوجيا الذكاء الاصطناعي في
منتجاتها وتعزيز تجربه المستخدمين
والمعركه بدات في نوفمبر الماضي عند اطلاق
تشارد جي بي تك مايكروسوفت ضخت عشره
مليارات دولار من الاستثمارات في شركه
اوبن اي المسؤوله عن شات على ان يدعم
روبوتو الدردشه نتائج متصفحها بنك اما
جوجل فاطلقت بارد هي خدمه محادثات تجريبيه
مدعومه من نموذج اللغه لندن الذي اعلنت
عنه الشركه في 2021 تقول جوجل ان اداه
ستتمكن من شرح اكتشافات جديده مثل تلسكوب
جيمس الفضائي لطفل يبلغ من العمر تسع
سنوات ايضا تكسر حواجز اللغه في ترجمه
جوجل متى تراقب المنافسين وتعمل على
معالجه المشكلات الاوليه في اطلاقها وتدعي
ان احد اصداراتها لاما يعمل
بشكل افضل من نموذج تشاتشي بيتي لكن لا ما
ليست التجربه الاولى لميتا في اغسطس
الماضي مثلا اطلقت برنامج بلندر بوت ولم
يكن بالكفاءه المطلوبه كما اطلقت جلاكتيا
المصمم لكتابه المقالات العلميه وفشله بعد
ثلاثه ايام فقط من طرحه
[موسيقى]
على كل اني ينضم الينا الخبر التقني احمد
الزرعوني سيد احمد اهلا بك معنا في
العربيه
ماذا يعرف عن لاما ما الجديد فيها وما
الذي يجعلها مختلفه عن باقي برامج الذكاء
الاصطناعي مثلا
السلام عليكم وشرفني اكون معاكم اليوم
طبعا
تقريبا ما في اي علاقه من بينهم هو مثل ما
تم ذكرة في التقرير هو عباره عن
روبوت يجاوبك على الاسئله يعمل لك
اختصارات يراجع لك البيانات اللي انت تم
ادخالها فيها سواء كان عباره عن اكواد
سواء كان عباره عن انك طلبت منه مثلا اكتب
لك رساله يكتب لك بحث علمي مع المصادر
يكتب لك تقارير لكن لا ما من ميته هو نفس
موضوع
من من ميته ميته طبعا عندهم
كامله اللي يسمونها هم رياكتب في برمجه
التطبيقات برمجه المواقع وبرمجه وهي طبعا
تعتبر من احد انجح الانظمه في برمجه
التطبيقات والمواقع اليوم لاما يكمل نفس
الموضوع ولكن في مجال الذكاء الاصطناعي
الانشائي مثل ما تبدا التقرير نعم طب يعني
اذا كلهم عم بيصبوا بنفس المجال يعني كلهم
عم بيصبوا بنفس المجال اليوم انا وين بدي
على اي واحد فيهم وهل تعلم لاما من اخطاء
بينج واخطاء تشاد جي بي تي وخصوصا هاي
الهلوسات الالكترونيه اللي كانوا عم
بيوصفوها المستخدمين مؤخرا من خلال
استخدام هذين لا هو طبعا هو مختلف عنهم
نهائيا هو عباره عن لغه هي اللغه تدبرمج
فيها وتتعامل معاها مع البيانات ما يعطيك
اي اجابات هو انت تستخدمها في انشاء البوت
فانت تنشئ بوت كامل من خلال اللامة هذا لا
ما نقدر نسميها هي اقرب الى لغه برمجه عن
بوتيجاوبك على احمد انا من رواد ومن
مستخدمي كيف يمكن ان تفيدني ما لم ادخل
على الفيسبوك
لا ما راح ما راح تشوفينا هناك هي مختلفه
نهائيا يعني هي لغه برمجه هي اكثر منها هي
لغه برمجه للاخصائيين اللي ينتجون بيانات
وينتجون معلومات ويستخدمونها فهي في
الواقع وفي الحقيقه هي ليست منافسه ابدا
ولا منافس حتى لبنج ولا لجوجل بارت هي
مختلف موضوعها مختلف نهائيا وكانت مثل ما
يعني شفنا في
ميته كان عندها ثلاث محاولات في مجال
انشاء بوت شبيه رجالي ولكن للاسف كلها
فشلت فشل ذريع جدا وحتى بعضها واحد اخر
واحد فيهم ثلاثه ايام فقط وتم الغائها
نهائيا لان سوى مصائب يعني اخطاء كثيره
جدا كانت فيه يعني
الموضوع مختلف نهائيا مع عشان نوضح ونخصص
الموضوع في ناس تستخدم تشات جي بي تي مثلا
في الدراسه وفي الجامعات ليلخص وا مقالات
كبيره ويلخصوا كتب يعني غش الكتروني
بالعكس
بدون جهد صار يعني بطل فيه جهد بسرعه
الذكاء الاصطناعي بجاوب اذا انا بدي اغش
عبر لاما باي مجال بالضبط لا صعب بيكون
صعب لا لازم تبرمجه بالكامل وتهيئه
بدي استخدم لاما
هي لغه برمجه ففي فرق كبير بين الاثنين
ايوه هي لغه الترجمه